[Applaudissements]
des sourires sur les visages des joueurs
versailles et après une saison intense
versailles est officiellement champion
de nationale 2 après sa victoire contre
plabennec à domicile pourtant rien n'a
été simple ce samedi 14 mai en première
période les joueurs de la cité royale
déjà assurés de la montée depuis fin
avril des jouets n'arrive pas à trouver
la faille 0 0 à la pause en tête un
petit manque de rythme l'équipe de
plabennec qui joue sa survie qu'ils nous
craignaient un petit peu de venir je
vais chercher champions c'est pas simple
pour eux il dit nous on avait déjà
acquis cette montée on a une petite
semaine de repos ça qu'on n'a pas mis le
rite qu'on était habituellement en
seconde période vers s'est accélèrée
marque dès les premières minutes avec ce
joli but signé cas possibles et versé
ils sont virtuellement champion malgré
quelques frayeurs sur coups de pied
arrêtés et demi finaliste de la coupe de
france résisteront aux assauts des
bretons et valideront ce premier titre
de n2 de l'histoire du club avec ce
score de 1 0
on est heureux bien sûr bien sûr qu'on
est heureux parce qu'on sait qu'on a on
a beaucoup travaillé pour résultat on en
sait beaucoup investi depuis le 1er
juillet c'est une fierté parce que c'est
quelque chose qui restera c'est un titre
donc ce qui signifie qu'on a été la
meilleure équipe de ce championnat sur
cette saison donc c'est une fierté
supplémentaire
on avait à coeur de finir comme ça là
aujourd'hui sur une victoire devant
notre public de finir cette saison sur
cette victoire et cette montée et ce
titre de champion cette demi-finale
franchement il ya trop de choses qui
passent par la tête c'est magnifique
devant notre public de faire ça on est
extrêmement contents de leur côté les
supporters eux se projette déjà sur
l'année prochaine et le championnat de
national parce que je donne à les
prochaines ainsi le niveau est beaucoup
plus élevé j'espère qu'ils vont soeur
moins se maintenir déjà et puis on verra
pour les années suivantes
mais avant de penser à la saison
prochaine vers c'est encore deux matches
à disputer ils refermeront cette saison
2021 2022 réussi le 28 mai prochain à
domicile devant leurs supporters au
stade maubon
[Applaudissements]